une soufflerie c'est un conduit en
boucle fermée ici on a un ventilateur
d'un côté et de l'autre côté on a une
zone de test dans lequel on teste des
objets ou dans ce cas-là des cyclistes
le ventilateur entraîne le flux d'air
dans le dans le conduit en boucle et on
a débit constant donc on se retrouve
avec une zone de test où le l'air arrive
sur le l'objet testé ce qui est
important c'est que l'air se déplace de
façon homogène et arrive de façon
homogène sur l'objet à
tester en soufflerie on réalise la
mesure de SCX c'est directement un
coefficient qui veut donner l'effort de
traîner aéro et on mesure aussi ce qu'on
appelle la pression dynamique c'est la
pression qu'on sent quand on met la main
par la fenêtre dehors et ça nous donne
ce coefficient de SCX qui va
caractériser la la qualité aérodynamique
de l'objet ou de du cycliste à
tester la qualité de la soufflerie le
plus qu'elle a c'est d'être une grande
veine donc ça c'est assez nouveau en
standard de pouvoir tester les
interactions entre cyclistes et de
regarder ce qui se passe quand on est
dans le sillage d'optimiser sa position
dans le sillage du du cycliste devant
soi et ça c'est un gros
plus les origines de ce projet c'est le
le projet de construction du du
Vélodrome à 51 enivelg on a un
savoir-faire en terme d'optimisation
aérodynamique pour l'automobile pourquoi
ne pas en faire profiter le monde du
cyclisme et plus particulièrement le
monde de la
FFC nos clients principaux sont les
constructeurs automobiles donc
l'opportunité que présentait la la
construction du Vélodrome c'est un moyen
pour nous d'élargir nos périmètres de
compéten
vis-à-vis du dorau mais aussi vis-à-vis
de l'aéronautique c'est faire connaître
notre savoir-faire dans d'autres
filières industrielles le territoire est
très dynamique j'en veux pour preuve ben
de l'autre côté de de notre implantation
de l'autre côté du boulevard vient de
s'implanter
Mercedes il y a le siège de BMW et
cetera donc ça prouve que que le
dynamisme il est
là